apawn and his Bishop he's always winning
because it promotes on a light Square
his Bishop will be able to kick the
black king out of the A8 corner but it's
not the same on the other side of the
board
so I think Vincent just covered the
wrong Pawn
unfortunately for him
and uh the king coming across
you know more advice unfortunately if
the king will eventually get that pawn
also Knights are terrible at stopping
Rook spawns because they can only stop
it from one side of the wood a pawn in
the center a knight can stop from the
right the left it can stop from in front
a rook spawn because the boat is only
eight files across
and Knight can only stop from one side
okay a check or Magnus gesture that was
a strange gesture was that like well
that doesn't help yeah kind of gesture
and now I think risks as well gonna
resign
oh wow what a game wow Magna is shaking
his head but after 93 moves a very long
game he takes a win in game three and
that means he also takes the lead